Speaker 1: . Now, let's talk about one statistic
in the U.S. that is pandemic related, that
is really not looking very good, and that
is that hospitalizations in the United States
are rising, not overall, but in areas with
low vaccination rates.
Now, we've been talking for months at this
point in time, if 20 percent of the country
never gets vaccinated, which the latest polling
we have is that 20 percent of the country
does not plan to get the coronavirus vaccine.
What's going to happen?
Well, we'll never eradicate it fully.
We may never anyway.
But in addition to not eradicating it fully,
you're going to see these clusters pop up
in the areas that have a lower percentage
of the population vaccinated.
And statistically speaking, most of the people
who get it will be the unvaccinated.
But the vaccines aren't 100 percent effective.
When we say 94, 95 percent, that means roughly
one out of 20 people who get vaccinated do
not develop antibodies.
So these unvaccinated areas will also lead
to some vaccinated people getting sick.
And statistically, if enough of them get sick,
some of those people are going to die.
This is happening now.
We had the idea maybe that would be at the
end of summer, maybe into the fall or winter,
where you would start to see these clusters.
They're happening now.
There's a new New York Times report which
says in the U.S., hospitalizations are rising
in areas with low vaccination rates.
Health officials worry that covid-19 hospitalization
rates could increase among the unvaccinated
as variants of the virus spread.
The coronavirus might be receding in much
of the U.S., this article writes, but it continues
to spread in communities with low covid vaccination
rates, where highly contagious virus variants
pose a threat to those who have not had shots.
As an example, the article mentions Smith
County, Tennessee.
Only 20 percent of the population in Smith
County, Tennessee, are fully vaccinated, and
there has been a 700 percent increase in hospitalizations
for covid and 19 over the last two weeks,
according to the New York Times database.
Another example in Truesdale, Tennessee, or
maybe it's pronounced Truesdale, a 23 percent
of the population is fully vaccinated, hospitalizations
up 700 percent.
This is not a coincidence.
Dr. Ted Delbridge says in most age groups,
people who become ill are twice as likely
to end up hospitalized as people who got the
virus earlier in the pandemic.
What does this mean?
This means that these variants are not only
more contagious, but more likely to make you
sick if you are not vaccinated.
So all else being equal, if you have 50 percent
of the population unvaccinated now versus
at some previous point now, more likely people
are going to get really sick and sick enough
to get hospitalized because of these variants
in Maryland.
Of those between 50 and 59 years of age who
got covid over the winter, eight percent were
hospitalized from April April on, 19 percent
of people in that age group who got the virus
were hospitalized.
And the vaccines protect you.
This is not going to stop.
This is not going to go away in this way.
And I know that there's a lot of tough talk
about I'm healthy, I eat a good diet, I exercise,
et cetera, that doesn't protect you from covid-19.
And as the variants that that are predominant
are more transmissible and or more likely
to put you in the hospital, you are taking
a real big.
Risk by being unvaccinated, but you were also
putting other people at risk at this point,
it's like a broken record.
I don't know how many times it has to be said
the vaccines are effective against the variants.
They are slightly less effective against some
of the most recent variants.
But you get really good protection from all
known variants so far if you just go and get
vaccinated.
And so we talked earlier about the numbers.
We're now down to about 14000 cases per day.
It's it's really quite low, some of the lowest
we've been at for for a while.
Where do we go from here?
Where do we go from here if we continue to
see this vaccine hesitancy?
So a little bit later, we're going to talk
about Biden's infrastructure negotiations
and some other things.
Later, we're going to actually have video
from a hearing where attendees were arguing
against any kind of required vaccination.
And the nuttery is growing significantly.
The nuttery is spreading like a virus.
So we're going to talk about that later.
We're going to talk about lab week, but send
me your thoughts.
How low do you think cases can go if 20 percent
of the population really refuses to get themselves
vaccinated?
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that our program is mostly funded
by memberships from folks like you who sign
up at Join Pakman Dotcom, you get lots of
great member benefits, including daily access
to the members only bonus show and audio and
video formats, as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show.
It's all happening at Join Pakman dot com.
You can use the coupon code better twenty
one to get a membership with a discount.